>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> [cheering] I am so,
so, so glad you're here.
We are thrilled to have you.
We're excited to be
in this conversation
and we completely honor
you for your patience.
[cheering] Really.
So I have a couple things that
I'm here to say and then I'm going
to introduce Jeff Kinney.
[laughing]
[ Cheering ]
Wow! [laughing]
So -- [crash] Oops.
Sorry about that.
So let me tell you a little bit
about the Library of Congress.
Raise your hand if you --
this is your first time here.
Welcome! Welcome.
So it's our mission here
at the Library of Congress
to provide a very rich,
enduring source of knowledge
and it's designed to
inspire and engage you.
And I am clear that you all have
some knowledge of Jeff Kinney,
some knowledge of "The
Diary of the Wimpy Kid" --
Greg, Rowley, some new
characters -- I'm a little --
my son's 13, so I haven't read
one of these in about a year.
But I know some of
the characters, right?
So it's our intention --
[microphone crash] We're going
to try this again.
[microphone movement]
>> All right.
>> I'm actually going to keep
talking while he does his thing
so we'll manage our
time accordingly.
So it's our intention at the center
for the book that we promote reading
and literacy and books and
libraries and poetry and literature.
And we do that because we feel
like they are the best tools
for you all to live lives of choice.
Like you get to say
how your life goes
when you know how to read and write.
And here at the Library of Congress
it's our focus to provide all kinds
of programming and
activities to do that.
So today's event is one in a series
that we have -- we welcome you to.
There's a special event
that's happening today.
Today is not just that
Jeff Kinney is here.
What else is special about today?
Does anybody know?
[inaudible responses] He's
signing the books, that's true.
What book?
What's the book?
[inaudible responses] "Double Down!"
That's right.
[inaudible responses]
And what's special
about today is it is his first
day of the tour for that new book.
[cheering] So he chose
to be here to celebrate
and introduce his eleventh book,
"Diary of a Wimpy Kid:
Double Down," with you.
[ Cheering ]
So just so you know,
these books have been
on New York Times'
Bestsellers List for weeks.
The books are translated
in 52 languages,
180 million copies have been sold.
So imagine how many of you there are
in this room and how many of you --
how many of you have
read all 10 of the books?
Raise your hand.
All right, great.
So number 11 is just
waiting for you.
How many have done like eight?
At least eight of the books?
All right, great!
All right, so listen, we're going
to introduce who's in the room
and then we'll be ready for Jeff.
[cheering] Hopefully.
>> Keep talking.
>> Okay great.
[ Inaudible Background
Conversations ]
We have a number of
schools in the room and I'd
like to just acknowledge them,
starting with the District
of Columbia.
We have Brent Elementary.
[assumed spelling]
[ Cheering ]
Got it?
And we have Kimble Elementary.
[assumed spelling]
[ Cheering ]
Welcome. We've got
Langdon Elementary.
[assumed spelling]
[ Cheering ]
True Sail Education Campus.
[assumed spelling]
[ Cheering ]
And I mentioned my son is 13, he's
an eighth grader at Two Rivers PCS.
[ Cheering ]
And we have the Graphic Novel Club
from Balue Senior High School.
[phonetic] Where are you guys?
Balue!
[ Cheering ]
All right, and from
Prince George's County,
Maryland we've got the
Benjamin Stoddard Middle School.
[assumed spelling]
[ Cheering ]
Gwen Park Middle School.
[assumed spelling]
[ Cheering ]
Did I miss anybody?
[ Inaudible Background
Conversations ]
Okay. All right, so we're in
the final stages of wrapping
up the technical difficulties.
So I thought I'd do this;
let me have all the parents
and the teachers and the chaperones
and the adults who made it possible
for you to get here to please
stand and be acknowledged.
[ Cheering ]
So I just want you guys to listen.
[ Inaudible Background
Conversations ]
Since we have a couple minutes
I just want to take the time
to acknowledge the parents and the
teachers and the adults that came
to make this event possible.
I want you guys to notice --
how many of you know that Ago --
[phonetic] [yelling] Okay, that
means -- let me have your attention.
Let me have your ears on, lips off.
I want to acknowledge the teachers
and the parents and the adults
that made it possible for you to
be here because it's a really,
really great opportunity
to have you be
so excited about books and reading.
And we know that it's not just
today's event and being here
that is what they did
to make it possible,
that every day you give your lives
to supporting education,
empowering children.
I'd just like to say, "Thank you."
And I'd like the students in the
room to say a big "Thank you"
to your teachers and adults.
>> Thank you!
[ Cheering ]
[ Inaudible Background
Conversations ]
--
So --
[ Inaudible Background
Conversations ]
All right, so I --
[ Inaudible Background
Conversations ]
I think we're -- we may be close,
but I don't have a signal yet.
So I want to hear from you
all, while they work this out,
besides Greg, who are
some of our favorites
in the 10 books we've read thus far?
[inaudible responses] Wait a minute.
Wait a minute.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Hold -- on, hold on, hold on.
This is where we can't hear all
the voices at the same time.
So raise your hand and I'm going
to call on a couple of you.
Dog Days! [cheering] Ready?
[ Inaudible Background
Conversations ]
Okay. All right, two more
and then he's almost ready.
Yes?
[ Inaudible Background
Conversations ]
Old School!
[ Cheering ]
Rowley Rules!
[cheering] Rogers Rule.
I didn't know Rodrick's Rules.
Rodrick's Rules.
All right, and it's my understanding
that we are actually ready.
So you'll have a little
bit of time with Q and A --
for questions and answers with
Jeff after his presentation.
Let's give a huge welcome
to Jeff Kinney!
[ Cheering ]
>> Hey guys!
Hey guys! [cheering] Wow!
[cheering] Hi everyone!
All right.
Thank you guys so much.
I know how frustrating it
was to wait for that long.
I'm embarrassed that we were late.
We were trying to get
here through DC traffic,
which did you know it's pretty bad?
>> Yes!
>> I didn't know that.
So I'm sorry.
And then we couldn't get
the computers to work.
So now we've got everything
going and let's start over.
Okay, thank you guys so much
for coming out here today.
It's great for me to
be home actually.
I live in Massachusetts now
and I have for 20 years,
but I started off actually
in Fort Washington, Maryland.
How many people have
heard of Fort Washington?
[cheering] Yeah?
[cheering] Fort Washington,
Maryland is where I started off.
And in my mind "The Diary of a Wimpy
Kid" world is here in the DC area.
Whenever I'm writing
or drawing "Diary
of a Wimpy Kid" stories I'm
thinking of my home where I grew up.
So that's Fort Washington, Maryland.
And there are lots of
things in "The Diary
of a Wimpy Kid" books
that actually happened.
So I wanted to show you a few.
Let's see if this works.
I had this imaginary clicker.
Right? Let's see if
this works, right?
Oh, it worked.
Oh, no. It didn't.
Let's hit command/tab there
and go back to the pressie.
[phonetic] We're going
to keep having problems.
Oh, hit left arrow a bunch of times.
You're -- something's
going crazy here.
[laughter] Okay, right
arrow one time.
Let's see how that works.
Right arrow one time.
There we go.
There we go!
All right, now we're on a roll.
[laughter] Okay, so
my friend and I --
we actually tried to build
the world's biggest snowman.
Has anybody here ever tried that?
Yes? We thought we could
build like a 50 foot snowman.
Right? It didn't work out.
Instead what happened
was we tore up all
of the grass and the
sod in our yard.
So we actually tore up my friend's
front yard with this giant snowball.
So we had this big brown meatball.
That's one of the things
that happened in real life.
One of the things -- how many
people here have an older brother
or sister?
Okay, they're tough sometimes.
One of the things that happened
to me was that my brother,
in the middle of the summer --
just like in "Diary of a Wimpy Kid:
One" -- he woke me up in the middle
of summer and he told me I was late
for my first day of school.
So here's this picture.
Right? You remember that picture?
>> Yes!
>> And then I went downstairs
and made myself breakfast
at about three in the morning.
So my dad found me like this.
Right? My friend and I
made a haunted house just
like Greg and Rowley did.
So we scared the neighborhood kids.
Charged them and then scared them.
And let's advance to
the next slide here.
We also did something very stupid.
We had a game where I would throw a
football at my friend; not so smart.
And that happened.
So he got hurt.
And also, with another friend of
mine, we actually got into a fight.
I don't recommend it, but
this is what it looked like.
We didn't know how to fight so
we kind of looked like this.
Right? Let's take another look.
Yeah, that was us.
We didn't know what we were doing.
And I was also on a swim
team and I hated to be
in the water in the cold.
Right? So I would go
into the locker room --
and you've probably seen
this in the books, right?
>> Yeah!
>> I was cold and so
then I did this.
[laughter] Right?
So a lot of the stories in "Diary
of a Wimpy Kid" happened
to me in real life.
And I would really recommend to you
guys that if you have funny things
that happen to you
in your real life,
write it down because you
could write 10-12 "Diary
of a Wimpy Kid" books
easy based on your lives.
And so I wanted to -- I'm
going to try a technical trick.
Let's see if this works.
Okay, we're going to go command/tab.
Right? And then go to the finder.
That's right.
Yeah. Almost.
Finder. [scared noise]
Command/tab and release.
We're going to do this.
You'll see.
Command/tab and release.
[laughs] Okay, so let's
go to the finder
in the bottom left hand corner.
You see that icon in the
bottom left hand corner?
Yeah, let's click on that.
Okay, great.
In a second we're going to launch
one that says, "Global Tour."
So I'm at the start
of a global tour.
This is -- I actually
wanted to start
where I grew up; where I started.
And -- but last year we actually
went around the world and we're
about to go around the world again.
So I wanted to show you a
video from last year's tour.
Is that okay?
>> Yeah!
>> All right, let's
see if this works.
So let's hit "play."
Hope we get sound and everything.
We don't have sound.
[laughs] I'll show you around.
Okay, so we don't have
sound, which is interesting.
Can we pause?
No sound. Okay, so I'm just going to
show you what happened on this tour.
We went all over the place.
We went to the UK.
We went to Brazil.
You remember from the Olympics?
[music] Oh, here we go.
[ Music ]
Japan
Thank you guys for checking
out that video and you saw
that I got all the
way back to my home
in a little town called Plainville,
Massachusetts, where
I have two kids.
Let's go back to the pressie.
So, yeah there we go.
We're getting the hang of it.
So I like to collect funny stories.
You know that's what I do
when I travel, from my life.
So let's take a look
at how I collect them.
So I recorded everything
in a sketchpad.
So I had this 77 page sketchbook
and I wrote down every funny thing
that had ever happened to me.
And so as I went along I think I
started writing smaller and smaller
because I was afraid of
getting to the end too quickly.
And by the very end, the
last page looked like this.
So every funny thing
that ever happened to me
in my life was recorded
in this sketch journal.
And I'll tell you a story that
happened to me a few years ago.
We actually got to go to the
White House and see the Obamas.
Right? And it should
have been a great day --
and it was a great day -- but
I'll tell you something funny
that happened.
You can see my two boys
over there to the right --
Will [assumed spelling] and Grant.
[assumed spelling] And
they're kind of bad, right?
They're kind of bad kids in a way.
They're good and they're bad.
But one of the things they
did was they said, "Hey,
when you read your book on
the White House lawn we want
to sit next to you."
You know, "We want
to get in on that."
And I said, "Okay."
You know I knew they
were going to misbehave.
So I said, "You have to behave.
You can't do anything weird or -- ."
You know, "Hey, I'll give you ice
cream if you actually behave."
Right? So here are my two boys
reading and sitting next to me.
Right? And what I found out was that
my younger son at one point he got
up and he read out of my lap
and it was a very sweet moment.
He was just learning to read.
And then afterwards I was like you
know, "You guys were really good."
So I gave them some ice cream.
Right? And then I found
out when I went home --
I watched the White House
website and I watched a tape
and when my younger son was
reading out of my lap --
let's see if I've got
the image right here.
Yes, my older son was spanking him.
[laughter] Right.
So now that's part of official
White House documentation now;
my older son spanking
my younger son.
Right. So lots of funny
things have happened to me.
Lots of funny things have
happened to you guys.
When I was a kid I got really
interested in cartoons.
I wanted to be a cartoonist.
My favorite reading was comics.
Right? [cheering] So I
liked Donald Duck, right?
I liked "Calvin and Hobbs."
Have you guys seen
"Calvin and Hobbs?"
>> Yes!
>> And "The Far Side"
was one of my favorites.
>> Yes!
>> Right? And so when I
went to college I decided
to create my own cartoon
character whose name was Igdoof.
[phonetic] So I'll show you
what Igdoof looked like.
[laughter] That was Igdoof.
I created him at the University
of Maryland and I thought
that I'd be able to take
Igdoof out into the world
and become a syndicated
newspaper cartoonist,
but it didn't work out for me.
And what I found -- I started --
you know Igdoof just has this kind
of weird look and you'll notice
there's one thing he's got
in common with Greg.
Do you see it?
[inaudible answers] His hair.
That's right.
What I found out is that there
are a lot of cartoon characters
who are boys who are
bald or nearly bald.
Can anyone tell me the most
famous nearly bald cartoon boy?
[inaudible answers]
Somebody said Caillou.
[inaudible answers] All right.
I heard Charlie Brown.
[inaudible answers] I
heard Charlie Brown.
So what I wanted to show you is
that here's how cartooning is
different from illustration.
In cartooning you're trying to
use as few lines as possible
to make the biggest impact, right?
So I'm going to draw a few pieces
of drawings and see if you know
which characters I've got
going just from a few lines.
Okay?
Let's see if this works.
All right, so how about this one?
All right, let's see if
you know from just that.
Now let's not all yell at once.
Raise your hand.
Up there with the green shirt.
Yeah. [inaudible answer] What?
Who's that?
[inaudible answer] Don't know?
Do you know?
>> Rowley?
No, I'm going to keep going here.
[inaudible answers] Now you know?
[inaudible answers]
I heard Bart Simpson.
Yes. Okay, how about this one?
[inaudible answers] I
heard Charlie Brown.
That's right.
Okay, I'm going to go
with just -- let's see.
Okay, this one takes
a few more strokes.
Okay? [inaudible answers]
Sponge Bob.
Yes. And isn't that
amazing that you know
that from just a few pen strokes.
I mean look how --
those are so few lines
and you guys know those characters.
All right, I'm going to do
just one line, a curvy line.
Now you can't yell out.
I need a hand raise.
Okay, it's a curvy line.
And I'm not that good of an
illustrator so let's try this.
Okay. All right, you
up there with the --
let's see, how about
with the hoodie.
[inaudible answer] What's that?
Big Bird? No, but kind of --
you're in the right family.
Yes? [inaudible answer] Manny?
No. [inaudible answers] What's that?
[inaudible answer] This is -- you're
going to be mad when I show you.
I'll show you.
[excited noise] That's
right, Woodstock.
Woodstock from "Charlie Brown."
I didn't do a great job, but
he's kind of like this, right?
And then something like that.
[yelling] And then with Greg
Heffley, you know I think
that you know -- from
Greg Heffley is that --
I think this is all I
need for Greg Heffley.
I think you might have
guessed it from that, right?
So what I think would
be fun to do --
what I want to tell you is that I
fell in love with a cartoon strip
when I was in college and
it was called "Big Nate."
How many of you guys
have seen "Big Nate?"
[inaudible answers] Yeah,
so let's advance that slide.
[cheering] So "Big Nate," this
is one of my favorite cartoons
and I wrote to the author
and he wrote me back
and then one day I looked in the
Washington Post and I saw this;
Big Nate had drawn his own comic
and he put Igdoof in the comic.
Can you see Igdoof up there?
[inaudible answers] And can you
name the other cartoon characters
that Igdoof is in that sticker with?
Just from those really
scribbly drawings?
Anybody? Who is in the
upper left hand corner?
Bart Simpson, right.
Who's to the right of Bart?
Can anybody guess it just from -- ?
I'll bet some grownups know.
That's Garfield.
Right. [inaudible yelling] So what
I really like about cartooning is
that you are just trying to boil
something down to its essence.
So you guys did a really
good job of guessing
which character I was
drawing from here.
And I'm going to invite a kid up to
draw -- to learn how to draw Greg.
And it's you.
Come on up.
[ Excited Noise ]
All right, let's give this a try.
Hi, I'm Jeff.
[inaudible answer] What's your name?
Caleb? [assumed spelling] Okay,
so have you ever drawn
-- tried to draw Greg?
Did you notice it's kind of hard?
Oh you -- could you
just draw him right flat
out right now with no help?
Or do you need a little bit of help?
[inaudible answer] Okay, so drawing
Greg -- it looks really simple,
but it's actually hard because there
is so few lines that if you mess
up a line everything looks wrong.
Right? So I'm going to show you
that I always start with the eyes.
Right? You can do that, right?
All right, right next to it.
Now make sure they're
far enough apart.
Yeah. Good.
Excellent.
And then I always go with the nose,
which is really just kind of almost
like a C, like a flat C, right?
All right, excellent.
And then this is the hardest
part; if you've ever tried
to draw Greg you know
this is the hardest part,
to draw a circle that's kind
of almost perfect, right?
And you stop right there, right?
This is going to be hard.
I promise.
[cheering] You did a good job.
Excellent.
All right, now the
three sprigs of hair.
Right? And then an ear.
Okay.
I like yours better.
I should have drawn him
that way to begin with.
And then is your guy
going to be happy or sad?
Happy? Okay, so we'll go happy with
Greg and why don't you draw there.
And what's your name again?
[inaudible answer] Caleb?
[inaudible answer] All right guys,
let's give Caleb a
big round of applause.
[ Applause ]
Now I wanted to show you, people
say -- have you guys seen --
you know the character
Manny from my books?
>> Yes!
>> Okay, so if I was drawing
Manny I'm going like this, right?
[ Background Conversations ]
He's a little bit like
SpongeBob, right?
He's got those buck teeth.
He's kind of like Gregg.
You know he's his brother because
he's got those three sprigs of hair.
There's Manny.
He kind of looks like a baby
alligator in a way, right?
All right, so people say, "You draw
Manny so many times -- and Greg --
you must be able to
do it blindfolded."
Right? And I think somebody
has a blindfold in here.
Where -- Jason Wells [assumed
spelling] where are you?
Are you in here?
He must be out in the hallway.
Do you see Jason Wells out there?
-- -- --
>> No.
>> He's got my blindfold.
Okay, I'm going to -- if I can't
get a blindfold fast I'm going
to do this -- I'm going to promise
you that my eyes are closed, okay?
Deal?
>> Deal!
>> Okay.
[ Background Conversations ]
All right, he's not
anywhere in the vicinity.
So here we go.
I'm going to promise you I'm going
to draw Manny with my eyes closed
and it's going to turn out perfect.
Are you ready?
And I might need a
little bit of coaching.
Let's see.
Okay, so eyes closed.
Right? Paper is here.
Okay, so -- so far so good?
Two eyes? Yes?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Oh shoot.
I've already lost my place.
The eyes? Are the eyes there?
>> Yes!
>> No? [laughing]
[ Yelling ]
Okay, I'm going for it.
[laughter] Am I on track?
Yes? [yelling] No.
Okay. [yelling] So we're going
to go with the mouth right now
and then we have the teeth, right?
And then the neck, right?
And then the ear.
Everything's connected now, right?
Okay. [yelling] Hey, that's not bad.
That's not that bad.
[laughing] So today is
a special day for me.
This is the launch of "Double Down."
It's my eleventh book,
which is very exciting.
And this one has a spooky theme.
So I'm going to show you some of --
how many of you guys have read one
or some of the "Diary
of a Wimpy Kid" books?
[yelling] A lot.
Excellent.
And show me real quick, I want
to know, you've got these paddles
and it's got two -- they've
got two books on either side.
Show me the one that you
like better and I'll know
which ones you guys like the best.
Oh, interesting.
Interesting.
Okay, I see "Old School."
"Old School" looks
like the most popular.
Interesting.
Oh, I also see "The Long Haul."
Okay, good to know.
So in lots of the "Diary of a Wimpy
Kid" books I have spooky things go
on, right?
So let's look at some of the
greatest hits of spookiness
in "Diary of a Wimpy Kid."
Oh, we're in a whole -- we're on
a whole different track right now.
Let's go on.
"Double Down," right?
There we go.
And here we go.
Right? [yelling] Okay,
that is Silas Scratch.
My dad made up that character,
Silas Scratch, and I took that idea
from him many, many years later.
All right, we also have --
in another book we
have -- Santa's Scout.
[yelling] Right?
Little bit scary.
And Greg's doll, which is Alfrendo.
[yelling] Remember?
One of the scariest
characters in the "Diary
of a Wimpy Kid" books
is Nasty Pants, right?
And then there's a girl in Greg's
class that Greg's really afraid of.
[yelling] Not -- he's afraid of her.
That's Ruby Bird, right?
She bites the teacher and then
the tooth ends up in his arm.
It's really gross.
So in this book I wanted to
do a lot of spooky stuff.
How many of you guys went
out for Halloween last night?
[cheering] Yes.
[cheering] I missed my first ever
Halloween with my kids to be here.
But I wanted to show you -- in
this new book I've got a parody
of the "Goosebumps" books.
So I've got spine ticklers.
Right? Spine ticklers.
So these are scary books that
really catch on with the kids.
Let's look at another spine
ticklers book right here.
"My Teacher is a Cannibal."
[laughing] So I have the
spine ticklers books.
I have geese that chase
the kids around.
[yelling] I have a witch that
Greg is really terrified of.
Now how many of you guys have
actually been scared of something
like this; your parent
buys a Halloween decoration
and it terrifies you.
Anybody? Yes.
So in Greg's world they put the
witch down into the basement,
but any little sound sets it off.
Right? So if you drop a napkin
upstairs the witch might go
off downstairs.
So they actually take the
batteries out of the witch
and then it still goes off.
Right? Very terrifying.
In this book Greg and Rowley
decide to make their own movie,
which is called, "Night
of the Night Crawlers."
It's about man eating worms.
Okay? And they use gummy
worms from Halloween --
left over from Halloween
-- to make their own movie.
So how many of you guys
have seen any of the
"Diary of a Wimpy Kid" movies?
Good. So you guys -- if we can
get our technology to work,
you're going to see something that
no kid in the world has seen yet.
So right now we're
filming a new movie.
We're filming "The Long
Haul" in Atlanta, Georgia.
Right now they're filming it.
And they put together a clip
so that you guys could see some
of the stuff that happens.
But I wanted to remind you of
what happens in "The Long Haul."
Let's look at this.
In "The Long Haul" we have the pig.
[ Inaudible Yelling ]
And Greg is carrying
the pig, that's right.
[ Inaudible Yelling ]
And they eat deep fried
butter on a stick.
Right? These are things that
happened in "The Long Haul."
So let's take a look.
Let's do command/tab
to get to the finder.
Just to the finder, that's right.
And then let's launch one
that says, "movie teaser."
So nobody's seen this yet.
Let's see if this works.
And we're going to need the
audio before we play it.
So let's not play it
until we have the audio.
[ Music ]
Hi, my name is Jeff Kinney
and I'm the author of the
"Diary of a Wimpy Kid" series.
And I wanted to tell you about
the new movie we have coming out,
"Diary of a Wimpy Kid:
The Long Haul."
[music] With the new movie
we have a whole new cast.
We've got Jason Drucker
as a pint sized Greg.
[inaudible] We've got
Charlie Wright as his rock
and roll older brother, Rodrick.
[music] We've got Wyatt
and Dylan Walters,
who actually fill the wall
of three year old Manny.
We've got Tom Everett Scott,
who plays the beleaguered dad,
and the loveable Alicia Silverstone,
who plays Susan Heffley.
[ Music ]
I can't wait for you
to see the new movie.
I think it's going to be the
best "Diary of a Wimpy Kid" yet.
So come on out and
get wimpy in 2017.
[music] What do you think?
[cheering] Cool.
[ Cheering ]
All right.
So there's lots of -- there are
lots of interesting things going
on in the "Diary of a
Wimpy Kid" world next year.
That's why this is an
exciting year for me.
Let's take a look at
-- and one more here.
[yelling] We had a balloon
in the Macy's Day Parade --
the Thanksgiving parade -- for six
years and now we've retired it.
So we made a new balloon.
So here's a sketch that
almost nobody has seen yet.
This is what the new
one's going to look like.
>> Cool!
>> So Greg is sort of
falling forward, right?
And we also made a musical that
ran in Minneapolis this year
and hopefully will
come to DC one year.
But you can see that Greg is
looking down at the cheese.
He's being warned not to eat
the cheese, or touch the cheese.
So I thought I'd do something fun.
I'm going to start working
on book 12 right away, but --
[yell] thank you very much --
but I need to put it together.
So I thought maybe we could come up
with the color and the title today.
Does that sound cool?
>> Yes!
>> All right, so I'm going to point
to three kids and you're going
to tell me a title --
a color that you like.
Okay? So right here.
[inaudible answer] Purple?
So we have one purple book,
but we can make another one.
A different shade of purple maybe?
Yeah? Blue?
Maybe a really deep blue?
That would be cool.
Yeah. [inaudible answers]
Did you say red?
Yeah, we have two red ones, but
maybe we could do a different shade.
Yeah?
>> Yellow.
>> Yellow?
Right. We -- [inaudible
comment] what's that?
>> Gold.
>> What? Oh, gold?
Oh, that's cool.
I like that.
And right there?
[inaudible answer] Say it again.
>> Silver.
>> Silver?
That's interesting.
Now how many boy -- if
we made a pink book,
how many boys would still
read "Diary of a Wimpy Kid?"
Thank you.
All right, how many
boys would not read it?
And how many people would
be in favor of a pink book?
Yeah? Interesting.
Okay, good to know.
All right, so now I want
you to do is think --
okay, so we have one minute?
Okay, actually we'll
get that one minute.
So what I want you to do is --
you notice most "Diary of a
Wimpy Kid" books are either one
or two words.
Let's say we come up with a
two word title for this book.
So just think of any
random word in your mind.
Don't say it.
Right? And we're going
to put two words together
and we're going to
come up with a title.
Now the rule is; I'm going
to call out one of the words
and then you can't change your
word, no matter what is said,
you cannot change your word
when I pick the second person.
Okay, you raised your
hand right away.
Do you have your word.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay, say it.
>> Banana man.
[laughs] Is that one word or two?
Okay, let's go with banana.
And then you with the pink.
>> Zebra.
>> Banana Zebra.
[laughter] All right,
let's try this again.
[laughing] Okay, hold on one sec.
How about you, over there?
[inaudible answer] Can
you name -- say one word.
[inaudible answer] Our
microphones aren't working.
Run? Okay, run.
And then this guy who's
shaking his hand like that.
Yeah? [inaudible response] Forkey?
[phonetic] [laughing] I
have never heard that word.
[laughing] Okay, we might need
to work on this a little bit.
How about --
[ Background Conversations ]
How about if we go to questions.
Do our microphones work?
Okay, our microphones work.
So I think we have about
10 minutes for questions.
Is that about right?
So let's get a mix of kids,
and if there are any teachers
who have questions, or grownups --
adults who came in --
that would be great.
So I'm going to trust you
guys to find the people
to get your questions to.
So I'm not going to be able to
get to everybody's questions,
but I am doing a signing
afterwards for those that can stay.
Okay. We've got this guy over here.
>> Car.
>> All right.
>> What's your question?
>> What -- do you have any
idea what would the new book --
the twelfth book's name will be?
>> That's -- well, it's
"Banana Zebra," obviously.
Right? No, we're -- you know what?
I usually don't have any idea
of what the books is going
to be all the way until
the spring of next year.
But this year I do have an idea.
I think it would be really
fun to do a travel --
a holiday book where
something big happens.
A big holiday book.
So "Cabin Fever" is a
really small holiday book,
but I want to do a
really big holiday book.
So I have an idea and
I can't say too much.
Okay? So we're going
to trust you guys
to find an audience
-- an audience member.
>> I'm Houston [assumed
spelling] and my question was;
what holiday is it going
to be, that you just said?
Christmas or Easter or
something like that?
His birthday?
>> Well, if you notice
with the "Diary
of a Wimpy Kid Books,"
I do them all in order.
So if the last one happened
in October the next one
happens in November, right?
And so this is going to
be the holiday season.
You know for me that
would be Christmas.
For other people it might
be something different,
but most people celebrate
something in December
and that's what it's
going to be about.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah?
>> Yeah, well my name is Chase.
[assumed spelling] And do you
have any idea for the new book
and like what is the story?
Like -- --
>> That's a good --
I can't say too much,
but something I've never
done before in the "Diary
of a Wimpy Kid" books is I've
never had them travel on a plane.
Now how many people here
have travelled on a plane?
A lot, right?
How many people have not
travelled on a plane yet?
A good number, right?
I was a teenager before I travelled
on a plane for the first time
and I think it's an
interesting experience.
So let's get another -- okay
we got somebody up there?
>> So are you going to like, not
only like travel on a plane, you --
I have a question that --
are you going to like make them
like go to like hotels and -- ?
>> Ah, yes.
I can't make it too similar
to "The Long Haul," right?
Where they went to
all these bad motels.
I'm -- so I'm going to
make this book different.
I think they're going to
spend time in airports.
Okay, we have another one coming up.
Way up there.
>> Tamari.
[assumed spelling] [laughs] Are
you going to add new characters?
>> Am I going to add new characters?
Yes. In this new book I have a kid
named Maddox, [assumed spelling]
who is really the opposite
of Greg in every way.
He's very different from Greg.
And if you notice in -- if you open
up a "Diary of a Wimpy Kid" book,
on the right hand side of
the page, the title page,
there's always Greg
verses a character.
And so in this book it's Maddox
because Maddox is really
the opposite of Greg.
>> Okay.
>> The -- on your title,
"Double Down" has like circles.
Does that relate to
like cheese or -- ?
>> That's right.
>> Anything in the story?
>> If you look at "Double Down"
you'll notice that the words look
like cheese and that's
because with this book I felt
like I was kind of starting over.
So I wanted to make this book
a lot like the first book.
So a lot of things that happen
in this book mirror what happened
in the first book, including
the reemergence of the cheese.
Okay, right here.
>> What -- are you going to
make a book after that book?
>> Oh, my gosh!
>> Am I going to make
a book after that book?
Yes. I'm going to keep going
hopefully until I drop.
[laughing] So we're going to
take about two more questions
and then I know some
of you guys have to go.
Some of you are going to stay,
but let's get these two questions.
>> What was the -- when did
you start writing books?
>> I started writing
when I was 25, right?
So now I'm 45.
So 20 years ago, right?
>> Wow!
>> Okay, so we're going
to do one more question.
Right up there.
And we have two girls there.
So we'll get both of them.
We'll do two.
>> What is "Double
Down" mainly about?
>> "Double Down" is about Greg
trying to become a creator.
He learns to play a musical
instrument and he makes films.
His mom really wants him to get off
the video games and make something.
And that last question right there?
>> Personally, what's
your favorite book?
>> Personally my favorite book,
it's always the latest one I wrote.
I'm really happy with "Double
Down," but I like "The Long Haul"
because it's the most
complete book I think.
I've gotten a little bit
better at this year after year.
So I think that's my best.
So guys, like I said, some of you
can stay and some of you can't.
I wanted to say first of all
again, I really apologize
for not starting on time.
I feel terrible about that.
Thank you so much for
being so patient.
Thank you for coming out here and
thank you so much to the Library
of Congress for having me.
[cheering] Take care!
[ Cheering ]
>> All right, how about that.
I know he can hear us back there
as he's going around to set
up to be able to do book signing.
So how about the loudest cheer
to say, "Thank you Jeff?"
>> Thank you Jeff!
[ Cheering ]
>> So hang on.
We're -- we -- just a couple
words before we dismiss.
And we are going to ask that you
stay seated as much as possible.
If we could have everyone
stay seated and dismiss
in an orderly fashion we'll do that.
So we'd like to thank you for
being here with us at the Library
of Congress and we also would like
to thank the Open Book Foundation,
who provided -- is supplying some
of the books for students today.
If you're a school
group and you wish
to buy more books they're still
available in the vestibule
and Jeff will be there doing the
book signing at the table outside.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.